i 100 with a fired
bro my cheeks clenched clenched
like slabs of stone
[Music]
here we go guys there we go wagon what
are you saying
welcome to april i hope you've enjoyed
it so far
um some of you may know some of you may
not it's my birthday month
it is 22nd is the date save it
[Music]
and utilize it i want everyone to have a
good day on my birthday
i'll be turning 30. um so let's try and
bring in
at least 30 patrons
on james's 30th 30 patrons of james 30th
that's the 22nd of april guys mark in
the calendar let's jump
in oh wow um yeah man no pressure if you
don't love us
that will show me exactly how much you
don't know and it's fine
um thank you to the guys that actually
abide by the rules set
um i also said a few weeks ago if you
haven't subscribed
and you want to tell me that you love
the pod and all this stuff
and i don't see your name in the patreon
like the patronist
then literally piss off and you're
blocked
bro everyone that's messaged me
personally in the last couple weeks
has added a little disclaimer at the
bottom oh yeah and i'm a patron
gang there you go we're boys
didn't even have to check the list yeah
so it's all good um
so guys jump on that patreon three pound
a month 10p a day
run me our p run us the p guys it's that
simple um
if you liked the video guys please like
the video let's jump it up to 700 likes
this week
700 likes is the number for this week um
and obviously guys we've been rummaging
through the reviews
on the apple podcast the spotify and
stuff like that you guys are awesome
five stars five stars on apple podcast
so let's go
and we want to make sure they have to
introduce a sixth star
for guys like us you know so keep
pumping out those um
those reviews and thank you guys so much
it helps us bump us up in the charts
um and reach more lovely is
so um guys if you're new if this is your
first episode
get ready because it's going to be a
doozy brother it's going to be
easy and jump on the merch as well
yeah link's in the description always
link's always in the description guys
merch is flying off the shelf so let's
keep it
let's keep it let's keep it bumping yeah
i actually never thought
that we'd consistently make profit on
much every month every month i thought
when we release a new lot we'll get a
spike and then we won't sell anything
again until we release another lot
but every single month you guys cash in
for us so we appreciate you we love you
we appreciate you guys um and you grease
our pockets nice
not nice enough obviously but you grease
it nice
so uh without further ado let's jump
into the show uh
yeah man hi guys we got another fun fact
for the day
so there are four countries in the world
that have no national anthem no lyrics
sorry no lyrics to the national anthem
it's just sound
um so you've got bosnia
kosovo san marino and
spain spain has no lyrics they've got no
official lyrics
so what do they do just no no no they've
got they've had um
they've had unofficial lyrics since the
first um since the first one so the
first
original um national anthem was in 1761
and it was just
music it was just moves then it got um
readopted in 1823
1874 and 1942.
who in god's name how do you spread the
word
and say guys just so you know we've got
a new national album
how does everyone know and you've got to
learn the thing
you've got to learn the new one oh my
days i have
no idea what a national lamp is apart
from god save the queen god save our
grace god save our gracious queen
god save our noble queen god save our
precious queen
god save our queen god save
us lovely queen god
something queen yeah it's literally just
gonna save the queen a million times
bear bear god save the queen because
it's less laziness
do you think it's gonna it must change
yeah it changes the king yeah it does
that's all that's not awkward it's weird
because obviously in our lifetimes we've
only had a queen
oh yeah and the lifetime before us and
the lifetime before us yeah
that's weird bro so yeah when it's king
everyone's just gonna [ __ ] everyone up
oh it's gonna be so weird but yeah
that's interesting i thought you were
gonna say mongolia in that list
because they do that throat singing
thing in it hey margaret you never heard
mongolian throat singing
no but it's like they go boy
is that actually words is that chinese
because if not i don't think that will
fly in today's
society society i don't know did
nickelodeon just make that up i don't i
i need to find out if um it's made up or
if it's actually chinese
guys if you speak chinese or if you know
something on the inside of nickelodeon
was it nickelodeon i'm not too sure
jackie chan adventures
and if you don't know what mungo
fadisaur means you're too young for us
yeah actually yeah wow you will be too
young for us yeah yeah yeah um
i don't know why i remember that i have
no idea why i remember
i hate when he used a [ __ ] talisman bruh
the raccoon or whatever
vex bomb bomb the dragon
get a dragon in the game you've got
dragon
tadpole i hated when he used the [ __ ]
one ah
obviously you got a spice up there you
go spicy you gotta mix it up man but
still
i just want the dragon every week
i hate it when you use a [ __ ] talisman
so dead that's
jokes yeah the adventures of jackie chan
was a
was a six six six show it was like a day
um
yeah like you said if you don't
understand what it is yeah if you men
don't know
i don't think you even can get to know
at this point yes that's
it's so far gone now that if you try and
watch tonight probably wouldn't bang as
much you know
oh no no no no there's so much better
[ __ ] than that now for sure
when we were kids that's that's the best
thing we've seen to that point
true you know because there are a couple
shows that i i would say are timeless
yeah yeah cartoon cartoon shows like
back in our day bro
beyblade used to bang
beyblade let it rip and then amanda let
it rip
beyblades were hard did you actually
have it do your own beyblades big man i
was ringing tournaments in school
tournaments from i was guest i had my
hybrid
i had the um hybrid i had a hybrid
so i used to use the um the base
of um so i used to use the base of i
don't remember any other names direct
was it dragoon
i don't remember i think it was dragoon
the main guy the main guy is one i think
it was called dragoon
so i use the bottom of his the weight
disc from the turtle don you know the
green one
i can't remember school good so the
weight disc there was a so the dragoon
bottom then the weight disc was a fat
one
yeah from i think it was like a turtle
kind of thing okay it was green
and then the top was kai's um
fasting yeah don't know what he was
called but he had a rapid one so i was
like let me just mix up the defense in
the office g
for the perfect combination i was
smacking man now you have the the actual
ring thing
yeah yeah we had the little plastic bowl
thing that was in there we used to go
off and i had the little dents in it
yeah
if you get caught in there you'll fix
you forfeited the thing straight
away livid bro and i had the extra long
string
so you know you can get the normal one
like that yeah and you can get the arm
one
uh i made my mom take me towards the
rest a day before the first tournament
she had to get me the arm thing
but the trick was to get the extra spin
i don't
remember this so get the extra spin with
actual trick was to get the
ripper out of the arm one and put it in
the baby one
okay because it was longer in the arm
because it had to the the arm bit was
like that fat
whereas this thing wasn't like that so
boy you put the long thing in this thing
you've won it's a wrap i was
so gassed off beyblades yu-gi-oh new
gear was dope
um pokemon obviously
obviously did you bang pokemon yeah yeah
yeah a lot more than
all the other ones i think pokemon was
one of the staple ones that i watched
like religiously i think
and then after that digimon yeah i would
like watched i
watched bro yeah bro and i played it on
back when game boy color
yeah yeah
[Music]
yeah boy um i've actually got a fan
theory about pokemon okay i had no
intention of saying it but it just
popped into my head
fan theory about pokemon is there's a
theory
that you know in i think it's in the
first or the second episode
you know when it's um ash on his bike
and pikachu won't go in his poke ball
and actually he puts pikachu in the
front of his bike
or under his jacket kind of thing here
and they're getting chased by
um i think it's like spearows
either pidgeys or spearows are chasing
them okay and it's raining and he's on
his bike and then they slip in the mud
okay i don't remember just keep going so
basically they're on the bike it's
raining they're running away from
sparrows or pidgeys
um and it's [ __ ] going down ash hits
like a rock or something
flips his bike and smashes and smashes
himself on the floor
okay and then all of the birds come down
to attack him and that's the first time
pikachu jumps up and does like a
thunderbolt and
[ __ ] rattles all of them um there's a
theory
that in that episode when ash flips his
bike
he actually smashed his head and was put
into a coma
and that's why um
and the whole kind of pokemon universe
is all of ash's imagination in his coma
and that's why he never gets older
that's why
pikachu is always his main pokemon who
never goes in his poke ball
and that's why officer jenny and nurse
joy are all the same people
because when he was kind of rushed to
hospital or whatever
he saw an officer that was officer jenny
so that's his that's his only image of a
police officer that he has
and when he got to the hospital nurse
joy that's the only image
of a nurse that he has so every time in
his imagination he goes to hospital he
sees police officer or whatever
it's either officer journey or nurse joy
oh wow
wow that's a good theory that's a really
good theory
i have never because i don't remember
pokemon to your extent
yeah yeah that is looking back at it now
and i can imagine
how it could have patted that way yeah
yeah yeah theory
there's also another theory that states
that um
because i think they had like a the this
is and i think they kind of spoke about
this more
after when we finished watching pokemon
and when we got a little bit older but
apparently there's like a big pokemon
war
okay like back a day okay um and that's
why
um in the theory all the men
die um in the pokemon war
so the ashes time ash's generation is
the first generation after the great
pokemon war
and that's why there are literally
pretty much no
adult males in the whole pokemon series
there are teenagers like ash and kids
adult women
or old adult men like professor oak
but there are no kind of like
middle-aged adult men hmm
none boy
cool theories people's fan theories are
fascinating they are
fascinating that is because you don't
when you watch the shows later you don't
pick up on these things until
afterwards you know i never for once
thought well i probably did when i was a
kid but
you just buy into it in terms of officer
journey your nurse draw you're like
cool you only buy into what you should
yeah you think about what they show you
don't think about deep into that
yeah so especially as a kid oh yeah 100
that's
that's so yeah that's that um i have got
would you rather
support for shits and gigs is brought to
you by manscaped who is the best
in men's below the waist grooming
manscape offers precision
engineered tools for your family jewels
they obsess over their technology
developments to provide you the best
tools for your grooming experience
manscaped is trusted by over 2 million
men worldwide
and we also have an offer exclusive
offer rather for our listeners
20 off plus free shipping with the code
sng
at manscape.com that's right guys get 20
off and free shipping with the code sng
at manscape.com
that's 20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com and use code
sng unlock your confidence and always
use the right tools for the job
with manscaped all right let's get back
to the show
would you rather say your ex's name in
bed yeah
or your girlfriend's best friend's name
in bed
wow that's a sticky icky
wow wow
would i rather say my ex's name in bed
or my girlfriend's best friend
[Music]
i think off the back of
i think just off the bat i would say my
ex yeah
purely because yes
i've already dug myself a hole you know
you can't you're in deep i'm in deep
there's no coming out of it
either option i'm in deep but i think
i'm deeper if i say they're
my girlfriend's best friend you've got
no justification no
justification you've got nothing to say
because why am i thinking about her
whilst i'm inside my girl
you know what i mean yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah why am i thinking about your best
friend when i'm inside your my gal
bro that's a wrap so you're rapping
right even though it's probably a rap if
i say
um my ex's name or it's a it's still a
fight slash argument yeah
yeah you've got but i've got i've got
foundation yeah you've got foundation
i'm sorry but it is what it is i've got
a leg to sort of stand on but if i
say the best friend nah i could never
you best move in with her
you best hope she loves you back you
must hope she loves you back
i could never you don't have a home
anymore i could never i could imagine
i couldn't that's a scary thought
that's a scary scary scare i'll get
stabbed
stopped i couldn't go sleep that night
imagine if you said it and she was like
it's fine
kisses you on the cheek just go to sleep
it's fine
like mid intercourse and she stops you
like it's fine kiss you i'm like oh my
going to bed
no no no no like you say it post i'm
saying you say it
you're like sorry sorry so you've
already wrapped the thing okay so you
say it
you immediately realized what you said
and you i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
i'm so i'm sorry sorry sorry
she's like babe it's fine it's fine
and then just kisses you and then rolls
over says go to sleep
she tells me to go to sleep she rolls
over close her eyes
like reaches over pat she needs to go to
sleep
i'm shaking i wouldn't sleep a wink
i couldn't i'm thinking about it and i
was scared yeah i couldn't sleep a wink
but i also couldn't let her know that
i'm not asleep
you have to i couldn't be there you'd
have to be
you'd have to cut up just which is
behind your shoulder
i couldn't let her know i'm awake
i know you got the she got the better of
you in it bro you know when you're
you're uncomfortable yeah but you don't
want to move yeah and if you do move
you have to make out like it's a sleepy
move yeah yes your tents are just like
it's just you just peeking vamp she's
just there
she's awake she's up i'm glad you're up
oh can't sleep no i couldn't have that
conversation
can't sleep i'll sweat bullets fam
i'll get defense oh that is
that's scary you can't take that back
the scariest thing i could think of
you can't take that back what would you
rather
what a would you rather 100 nightmare
nightmare
it has to be the x day oh 100 it has to
be the
100 you're literally not allowed to do
the other one
you're not allowed to do the x but
you're not allowed to do it
ah i've actually got one for you that
phantom to me
or would you rather come on would you
okay scenario right
this is this is this is it's it's not my
one but it's dark
i bet i know which one it is gone all
right i don't know if you mustn't might
have sent it to you as well then
um you're
it's dark remember you're two inches i
knew it i used the mom and dad one yeah
i already knew
no one sent it to me how did you know
9 000 people sent it to us oh is it
oh i've not even seen it it's the most
popular one we've ever received really
oh as soon as i read it i was like oh
disgraceful god it's disgraceful
oh my god i'm going to say it i'm going
to say anyway for
the team so you're um two inches
into your mum and your dad is two inches
into you so you're in so for context
guys
his dick is two inches inside his mum
and his dad's dick is two inches inside
his [ __ ]
which way do you move to get out do you
go in
to get your dad out or you come out
and go inside your dad to pull out which
one would you rather
you mean my dad inside me so your dad's
yeah your dad's here yeah yeah
you're in the middle yeah so i either
get my dad out of me or i get my daddy
and me
yeah boss i'm going in my mum
um i i've see i've read it so many times
now and i've never known what to say
until now and it's gonna be dad
go back into your dad back into my dad
back up into my dad
explain yourself i have to back up into
him
i'll firm it i'll bite the pillow and
two inches he's already done it
he's already done it he's there
he's there that whatever's
left is is irrelevant to me
it's a nightmare but
i'm not i'm not thrusting i can't
i physically can't do you understand me
[Laughter]
i can't push forward i can't push
forward
because everything if i push forward
i'll never make love to a woman again in
my life
i know that for a fact but like as
as you already said though with your dad
you're already there bro
i'm already there but i'm not feeling
nothing
when you're banging i don't know when
you're banging
when you're imagine yourself being two
inches inside yeah and you just stay
there
it's nothing now if you
if every entry going further is euphoria
for you
ah you know i mean yeah yeah
so there's no way i'm doing that
with this thing i can just bite down
and put up [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] and it's
just like a
it's just like a pain threshold thing
for me i won't have to deal with the um
incestuous ramifications do i mean for
me it's just
a pain threshold and i deal with the
pain
and then i hop out and run
but i don't obviously never speak to my
dad again
just emancipate myself immediately yeah
but
the um the thrust i couldn't
because every single time i ever get
intimate
yeah with my love again mental blockage
is up yeah
if this no if i've done that to my
mother
this to anyone else never again never
again
i might as well castrate myself because
i'm useless at that point
but if i've if i have to deal with this
it means i could probably suppress
that i could probably forget i was ever
in there yeah if it means that i have to
force myself through this yeah i'm not
going in there
i don't care how many inches already was
when i woke up and i get how many inches
i was
i'm not going in there what would you
pick
oh i'm killing myself you can't kill
yourself
how i don't know the same way how
starker's in bed
sandwiched how are you kidding yourself
i'm gonna i'll just bite my own tongue
or science i'll batman tongue and bleed
out
bleed that all over oh my god
oh that's funny i just that's just it's
not it's not a fair predicament to put
anyone in
it's not how does one even get in that
position you don't i just wake up and
that's that's where you're at
you'd have to get chloroformed someone
has to drug you
i'm assuming you've been drugged
your dad's been drugged and um you've
you and your dad have both been drunk
and popped popped up viagra's yeah
that's what i was thinking and your
mom's just been tied up and drugged
yeah and everybody worked and just bare
vaseline or something bag of vaseline
yeah it's gonna have to be
yeah yeah yeah and then they just human
centipede the thing
and leave you to it and you just all
wake up at the same time wake up
huh huh i would scrape that obviously
because i'm facing forward all i can see
is margin just mum here and you're march
but i'm i can hear you feel the pain let
me just
i can feel satin in my rear end
bro and you're you you feel it it's a
sharp
and you clench up and then it's it's
just there it doesn't clench yeah it
catches and you can feel
the sun
nah and one of them once thank you that
i'll scream to the top of my lungs i'm
telling you i'm biting my tongue and
bleeding all over it
i'm killing myself oh no i'm killing
myself oh
no no no no no i've had if i had to
answer i would i would go for the same
one as you did
yeah only because i'm so happy you
answered first as well
because i didn't think about it yeah i
thought about an answer yeah
you know but after listening to your
justification it makes sense
because i've i physically wouldn't be
able to get that ahead anymore
if i thrusted him never again it would
give me nightmares for the rest of my
life
i would never sleep again i would never
sleep with anyone again i would never be
intimate with anyone again i would never
speak some like i would never look my
mom in the face again like nothing
that is um yeah thanks for that one guys
yeah that's disgraceful behavior that is
um
i could never anyway speaking of butts
do you remember when we had the um
there's a story i've never told you
about you or i told you but i missed out
details
okay um about when we used to do the
naked butler job
okay so
there um for context
there was a time where if you're new
here you don't know this me if you had
used to work
as topless naked butlers so we'd go to
like hen parties and
stuff like that uh i think i went to a
gay dudes birthday party one time
um and we'd do like events we had like a
slimming oh you didn't go to a slimming
world event did you
no um so you go to events and stuff like
that and you just serve champagne
and you got your breasts out um and then
if it's like a hen party they'll
probably pay extra and your butts out
and all this stuff right so i was at a
party one time
and you have to do a lot of um how do
you explain it you have to do
a lot of grooming to your area isn't it
so this was early doors this is what
like my
one of my early jobs second like first
five jobs easily mm-hmm
and um obviously your boy's hairy in it
your boy's hairy at this point you are
hairy james i am harry um
the hairy is back it's hilarious
it makes no physical sense why would you
say that
it makes no physical sense oh at the
bottom
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i was going to say fam that thing is not
attractive
don't run that don't say that
don't spin lies into my own tail
but yeah the bottom bit oh yeah oh yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah continue but um
that's made me laugh
um yeah the bot yeah yeah
anyway so um obviously yeah
yeah as a man yeah hairy you got your
pubis your ball fro
um and then you've got your bomb fluff
true so
i was in a rush g and i remember we'd
been in a rush before
on our first ever job and we did it
like i know you did a shave away and i
did a shave away
but it was rushed in the shower every
time because we were rushing for this
job as well
i remember the bumps and bruises i had
after that
the rash i experienced after that was a
nightmare really
nightmare so
i remember thinking like i need to prep
for this one but again i was in a rush i
was busy in the day yeah
and the only option i had was like
because obviously i heard like barber
clippers or whatever because i ain't got
time for this
um and the only option i would have had
was like a straight razor
so i was thinking uh i can't i can't
deal with these bumps and bruises again
i literally physically can't yeah so i'm
just gonna i'm just gonna have to go
how i am and obviously i keep it
maintained yeah
so it's not like a jungle yeah yeah
these men are still gonna
experience what they experience yeah so
um i get to the job everything's going
hen party
these yachts are drunk it's the same job
that i told you
when i went to the toilet and one one
yeah yeah
one woman offered to help me get dressed
and i was like i'm good i'm all right i
was scared never just get in my life
so i must have been like what 19 19
around this time
so um i'm there and i'm [ __ ] i'm these
men are having shots i don't remember
i'm cutting up line
limes so i'm in the kitchen cutting up
limes firm
bear in my mind painting a picture i'm
at the desktop in the kitchen
the women are over here galavanting and
i'm just cutting limes
breasts out arse out bro as i'm as i'm
cutting
i feel a sharp pain in my cheeks sharp
in or on on the cheeks okay sharp
i jumped out my skin jumped out my skin
i was ah
i didn't know what it was i thought it
was a dog or something i thought it was
a dog or something
i'm not joking i thought these might
have got animals up in the air yeah yeah
yeah
i turned around it was a grown-ass woman
on her hands and knees
she bit my ass
she never told me she bit my ass with
vigor i i couldn't see but there was
definitely a mark left there
definitely a mark i 100 with a fired
bro my cheeks clenched clenched
like slabs of stone clenched i left i
looked back
felt i've never looked back so fast
before animal
grown-ass woman on her hands and knees
bit me
i look back and she was looking up at me
like this
fam no word of life look at me like this
shed a hair on her lip twizzled
so she's trying to be sexy on a lipstick
blood red lipstick
this thing no they've been embarrassing
my life
no never been so embarrassed in my life
no
you have never told me that story you're
right never been so embarrassed in my
life
i can fully imagine never been so fast
in my life
[Laughter]
james never been talking about
nah never been so embarrassed i'm hard
but on the bright side
what i didn't have then but what i do
have now is
true cheeky manscapes manscaped guys
it's the one so um guys jumped in
jump in get your manscaped enjoy never
have the same issues that i had to
experience
never go through that level of
psychological trauma um
and forever move forever move guys stay
smooth and forever move
stay smooth and forever move gang gang
fam you've never told me that story can
you blame me
obviously not but can you blame me jesus
that is wild i would have fighted in a
[ __ ] face
you panic fart a lot i know you do i
just that would surprise
the christ oh yeah i've never been so
surprised i've never been so surprised
i was 110 certain it was an animal
i promise you there's no way that i
thought that was a human
grown married everything woman mum
[ __ ]
no couldn't do anyway um we've got an
awesome final question this one's a
little bit different and i really really
really really like this one okay because
it's very different
but i'm here for it it's what we're used
to so hey fellas i'm just looking for
some advice
i am a young single mom and my son is
nine years old
i know we're a couple years off puberty
but i want to be as educated as possible
as being a female i don't have any
experience
i've noticed on a couple occasions he's
had some body odor
and i've got him using some deodorant
and nipped it in the bud early
good he doesn't have many close male
figures in the family to talk to
his dad is in the picture but he's a bit
of a scruff so i don't really want him
picking up any hygiene habits from him
can you give me any advice in regards to
younger male hygiene
grooming and general body changes
is there anything you wish you knew
earlier growing up
or is there things you didn't know that
your parents hadn't told you
about told you about and you had to
learn about yourself
or maybe just the way your parents went
about these kind of conversations
that you really did or didn't like thank
you for
any help you can give me looking back
i actually physically can't remember
like my parents given me or my dad for
example
giving me advice or like pre-prepping me
or giving me knowledge about
puberty growing up sex anything i don't
remember
if he had he may have obviously when i
was a lot lot younger
but nothing nothing at all sticks in
mind the deodorant thing i had that
i remember my mum buying me deodorant i
don't i don't obviously
we all use dirt now but i don't remember
my parents actually buying anymore like
the first time yeah
or i don't remember the first time my
mum gave me deodorant but i do remember
there being
a time i didn't use deodorant at a time
i did use deodorant but
there was definitely i remember there's
definitely never like a conversation
like oh you're growing into yours and
you're gonna need to start using this
because you think it's just like
my mom knew i knew what deodorant was
yeah she bought me the deodorant
put it in my room you're just gonna have
to use this i think
i think in terms of like advice she's
asking for
how do you eat nine nine what year is
that do you know year nine is like year
f
uh five you have prime for primary
school is year five
see i think in terms of advice
the best i think how i went about it was
um just chitchat with my current peers
at the time you know
yeah the boys at school boys at school
not necessarily in primary school
because i don't remember that
that far back but without a shadow of
doubt like
in secondary school the people he meet
he wouldn't meet in secondary school
other people that would probably shape
him and
teach him the stuff that not necessarily
you might be uncomfortable to say
but some of the things you might not
even know about yeah
clearly because he's you said he doesn't
have a stable [ __ ] like a male figure in
his life
yeah yeah yeah i feel like he can learn
some other things from
the boys in and around his school or
like he's click or his circle yeah
um i think like
i think like um first of all
the deodorant was a good move that's
essential early on you need to he needs
to pick that habit up
from jump i don't remember when i wasn't
using it to when i was or
i can only remember using it yeah
yeah i know you mean so yeah that's
essential um i think i
as well because my brother and sister my
sister's nine
and my brother's 11. so alex and sophia
um so yeah they're going for it now
so i i remember last time i went i could
smell my my little baby sister
and i could smell it you know like uh
flipping
body odor and i'm just like nah
my little ting no
a little what's happened ah nah and um
so deodorant essential because that's
not something you want the boys at
school picking up on before your mom
picks up on it
that's just that's a nightmare i would
as shameless of a plug this is
fam as soon as he gets into year seven
hook donnie up with some manscaped
because i wasn't dealing with i no one
told me to to groom my [ __ ] oh no one
told me
until i was like 15 16 and talking to
girls
and i got told by a girlfriend
i got told by a girl that i need to trim
up my [ __ ] do you know how embarrassed i
was
i was like 15 something something just
start to get to the stinkies
the stinkies and the fam i'm just
getting to the stinkies and the strokies
and after a few sessions with this lady
she says to me
i can't remember what word she used but
she
came across the topic of basically said
in the nicest way possible
you could do with a bit of for lack of a
better word literally manscaping
you could do with a bit of grooming damn
and i was like
uh i didn't even know that was a thing i
thought like
i thought that would make me a [ __ ] in
my head i was like you know i think i
thought that back in the day as well
like armpits as well like i remember
thinking i remember the first time my
boy i was like 16
and my boy came out and he shaved his
armpits and i was like
[Music]
and that's all you know at the time i
was like oh [ __ ] jump is gay
but it took like another year for me to
be like i should probably shave my
office
but this is get out of control
so i would say to i would say to you nip
it in the bud
early yeah that my man needs to
keep his [ __ ] trimmed yeah literally if
someone had bought me a manscape box
when i was a kid yeah
just left it in my room i'm just
figuring it out figure
it out you're gonna need it figure it
out yeah yeah because when i got told by
this girl oh you need to trim your [ __ ]
up
bearing in mind i was 15. i didn't have
a job i didn't have any money and i sure
as hell was not going to ask for
clippers
from my mom for what what what do you
want to use
i go barber every week what do you need
clippers for there was no way i was
going to ask her
so i remember my stepdad had an old
crusty pair of clippers he didn't use
anymore
fam i would sneak in this room use it
clean it and put it back and i knew he
didn't use it anymore because he had a
new one because he was bored he used to
shave his head
he had a new one so i just didn't i
didn't have any guilt he's getting my
ball hair on his head
dick
so um yeah i remember that and that was
embarrassing for me
and i remember i had to do it in my room
because there was no plug socket in the
flipping
bar through bathrooms i had to do it in
my room then get downstairs get the
hoover
hoover up my room you shouldn't have to
go through that
that's embarrassing that's embarrassing
so hook him up just from early literally
get him a mousekit box
put it in his room and literally figure
it out trust me you're going to need it
figure it out and he will be grateful
that he doesn't have to have that
embarrassing conversation with you
true he's never going to want to have
that embarrassing conversation no man i
don't think anyone wants to kind of
have that kind of conversation yeah but
it's so much better if he learns early
please do not let him be like me
and get told by a girl that he's
chatting to that needs to trim up his
[ __ ]
because that is brutal brutal
it could do with a little bit of this
damn i was bright red bro i can imagine
i can imagine the thing with me is that
i
obviously i grew my [ __ ] i take care of
myself but i think i only ever started
to do it
properly around i want to say
post uni oh yeah like
i think it was more of a how can i put
it more of like an even stevens kind of
thing because
when i want to go down on a girl i i
like to see something nice and it
doesn't have to be like
clean off you know it could be stubble
it could be that like but
i like the presentation yeah yeah yeah
of course i like i enjoy it and it makes
me want to go down on you even more
so i thought you know what maybe they
think the same thing when they're trying
to slot man off so
i returned a favor in it fair play g i'm
gonna clean up a bit
yeah yeah yeah you guys give you guys
extra room extra wiggle yeah yeah
i think from then from when i had that
mentality i've been cleaning up ever
since
yeah yeah yeah that makes sense i think
that's probably why as well
i remember the first time when you said
about the little um
this fluff thing on my lower back and
then you man we're just like oh yeah
this is not
in uni oh yeah this was like the second
third or you know whatever last time
um years ago and i remember because i'd
already been grooming up
for years before then since 15. so i'm
already like five years in the game
[ __ ] i was working five years in
the game so when you remember chat about
that because obviously i was when you've
seen that i'm between grooms
and i'm thinking about i'll trim it
tomorrow
chill out are we boys or not are we boys
or not
little did i know obviously your man's
got a little bit more testosterone than
the other guy
it's fine i didn't know that i don't see
other guy's body hair like that
it's fine i know that now my brother
goes through it my brother
goes through it bro
he goes through it he's gonna need
discount code sng
really for twenty percent of free and
free shipping might as well gee bro
he goes through it um if you think i'm
hairy
i'm nothing compared to my brother he
goes through it like grown man goes
through it
damn like i get little speckles on my
chest
little tummy fro um like little what's
it called snail trail yeah
yeah so yeah i get like chess specs
which i think the longest i want to i
think beginning of lockdown i actually
tried to let it grow yeah just to see
yeah like [ __ ] it why not and i think it
got like this
my guy can get the whole bruce wayne he
can get the whole thing
everywhere that's the austin powers
thing oh
no that's hair actually it's actually
impressive that's hair
yeah yeah but then i get like it's mad
because then
i think oh but that means you can get
the man of steel do you
remember the thing we're talking about
when he comes out of the lake or
whatever and he's just
he's just there i was just thinking
about that not necessarily the man of
steel per se but i remember there was a
time i was growing mine out because mine
can grow to like
a little bit of whisk but it covers it
can cover the thing but i always clean
my chest
but there was a time i left there and i
don't know why i think maybe you know
when
you just don't have time to do anything
yeah and i was like [ __ ] let me leave
it to grow and this is when obviously
gyms were still open
and i was banging gym i was banging gym
obviously chest table it looks good
and i just looked at myself thinking
this actually looks like a
lumberjack sexy you feel like a
lumberjack massive
with the hairs and everything i felt
like a man it feels different
it feels different it does it does it
does it does it does it
does it doesn't matter yeah yeah yeah
yeah man
um so yeah um i would say literally get
him some grooming wear
leave it in his room keep going with the
deodorant
uh was a great shot is there anything
else
i think that's literally it there's no
other advice because i
i wasn't given advice by my part i
wasn't giving advice for sure i wasn't
giving advice to my parents i think it's
just stuff that i learned
as i was growing up through school
through friends and blah blah blah yeah
i mean yeah i definitely remember the
deodorant thing from my mum so props to
her for sorting that out
but again i don't remember us having a
conversation i'm pretty sure she just
knew i knew what to do with it
i just left it there um
but yeah giving him good hygiene habits
early on
is essential bro i went to school with
kids that didn't even brush their teeth
twice a day cuz
and then say with chest
there was a lot of um there was a lot of
smelly guys in my school bro smelly guys
in my school
so many guys like wouldn't have a like
barely have a shower
obviously i told you about dolly that i
used to throw a pen in his head top
um never brushed their teeth
definitely wouldn't like groom
themselves and stuff like that and it
was just like
mad and it's funny that you say about
like obviously you learn
advice from the mandem i remember i had
a little [ __ ] um
mexican mustache when i was younger in
it do you know them little
bum fluff ones and i remember thinking
one day i was like i think i just want
to trim it down bruh
because i'm not getting nothing around
here and it's not real hair like it's
not like solid hair
it's just a wispy thing it's just
butters it's just bars yeah and everyone
was like
do not shave it bruv because if you
shave it it's going to grow about thick
i was terrified i was terrified bruv and
i remember once i went to the barbers
and the barber shaped it thinned it out
i was thinking oh my god the top is
going to grow back thick
the top is going to grab my thinking
this business is going to be wispy
i was terrified i needed a man to tell
me the truth oh my
days i needed a grown man to tell me to
shut up
shut up you have no idea what you're
talking about brother oh my days
that's funny um but yeah but hopefully
that helps sorry if it doesn't
uh but that's a really good question
though that is a really cool that was a
really really good question it made us
think
and made me think anyway and i like it's
very different to the
to the norm the basic sex stuff
uh which we love but it's nice to mix it
up it's always great to mix up yeah man
yeah man
uh but yeah should we wrap it up no i've
got my segment oh yeah first
new segment guys i've got a new segment
so james has no idea what it's about
what's
called and blah blah blah i've got the
board ready
so for the audience turn the face away
please jimmy i'm going to show you what
it is and what it's called
i don't know if you actually can see on
it i've written all down before
um so basically james you can look now
rather okay
it's called one's gotta go one's gotta
go okay it's gotta go um it's
uh it's a normal concept i think you
would have seen on like twitter or
instagram or whatever
so you have four things or five things
or three things and i say them all that
and you gotta choose one that's gotta
leave
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah cool how many
things is it
so this is this is all how many rounds
or whatever there's
five okay cool but this is all tv
orientated tv and shows orientation i've
got so many different segments
oh i said i was doing data yes i've got
loads
gang i've got loads i'm impressed
already go i'm ready
cool gang gang gang gang gang okay
one's gotta go this is the first one
yeah yeah got breaking bad
yeah game of thrones yeah prison break
yeah and vikings prison break prison
break's gotta go yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and i love prison
break but it just can't compete with
that caliber of show okay
we'll come back yeah yeah yeah next one
shingeki which is attack yeah
mha which is my hero academia jiu jitsu
kaizen
or kimetzino yeba which is demon slayer
one's gotta go jiu-jitsu kaisen demon
slayer
attack on titan on my hero academia
one's gotta go
bro this is sophie's choice you're
basically asking which kid do i want to
kill
oh my god jiu-jitsu kaiser my hero
academia
demon slayer or attack on titan
one's got a gopro you guys as well you
can play at home oh it's a good one in
it
that's extremely difficult
oh god i feel sick
right this is almost disrespectful
because
jiu-jitsu is not even finished its first
season
but it's crazy disgusting
it's crazy isn't it
bro and the thing is i love my hero but
in that lineup it might be on the
chopping block
i think i [ __ ] my hair has got four
seasons though bro i know do you miss
layers got one
i love demon slayer i [ __ ]
demonstrate
demon slay is heavy demonstrate is
[ __ ] heavy i i don't
get i love demon slayer it's up there up
there for me
it is um right i'm gonna say the one
that's gonna go
is
i love attack on titan as well
it's either going to be attack on titan
or my hero
you tell me and both of them are have
the longest
both of them are the longest season four
season four season one season one
yeah [ __ ] but demonstrate and jiu-jitsu
are two of the best first seasons of
anything i've ever seen in the future
might be my best first season of almost
anything probably
it's it's too disgraceful yeah there's
two arms but anyways two arms
i'm gonna get rid of
i'm gonna get rid of attack on titan
because i feel like or do you want me to
go through all of it and then explain it
no no no no no
i feel like first of all attacking titan
is on his
last episode like the next week yeah
um and i just feel like
attack on titan gave us what was it
season three that was [ __ ] [ __ ]
so season no season two was [ __ ] no no
no no season two part one it was season
three part one
season three part one i didn't even
watch it
i watched two episodes i watched the
whole thing but it's only because i
watched the recap before i started
watching season four that i realized
how important season three part one was
i'm only realizing that
now when they're doing all this this
chit chat i'm thinking what's this who's
what yeah yeah yeah what are you on
about
all this political [ __ ] family what are
you honest season three part one was
too much chit chat boring but season
three part two
oh arms arms it literally made up for
the [ __ ] season before it
so but it's gotta go because of that and
i just feel like
my hero can't go because they're set in
waves
i feel like these man my i feel like my
hero are
progressing a story that they want to
last for the next 20 years
you know what i mean season four and we
still ain't seen [ __ ] [ __ ] to be fair
there's so much
so much we ain't seen [ __ ]
that's because he's only blaster in his
what kicks is it is he only yeah he's
only mastering these kicks
i think the most he was on five percent
we haven't seen you we're seeing [ __ ]
and then you've got all of the um the
league of villains
um the fire guy he's done one episode he
never come back
we've got bear she's got better [ __ ] to
do okay so yeah uh my hero has to stay
attack and it has to go unfortunately
even though season four
is wham season four's wham
but unfortunately second time has to go
cool okay cool ah that was a really good
question
really good i knew it would be you'd
like the next two all right cool there's
three more
um rick and morty south park
american dad simpsons
just out of legacy
south park and simpsons have to stay
this is the reason that's
purposely the reason why i put south
parking symptoms in there just out of
legacy if it was my
preferential taste simpsons would go i
know
i loved simpsons as a kid but i couldn't
give a [ __ ] about it i'm surprised that
you're still coming
um but i already know who you're going
to choose by the way
i'm just going to put it there i'm going
to circle it and let the fans know
so that's who he's going to choose so
what are the options again so you've got
rick and morty
yeah south park american dad and
simpsons okay and i think he's going to
choose this one american does go in
yeah that's what i said okay greg does
going i knew it
and i do really like america i know you
do i know you do but rick and morty
there's never gonna recommend going no
south park i know you [ __ ] love south
park i love south park and simpson's
legacy that's why yeah cool um i was
gonna put um
family guy but i prefer american that's
fine again that's why i put it right
anyway next one naruto
bleach
you know what's tough about that what is
that
i really enjoyed i've allowed myself to
be
kind of peer pressured into liking full
metal alchemists more than i did
because people adore it brotherhood not
another one yeah
brotherhood i've seen both of them i've
seen both of them but former mental
alchemist brotherhood was
[ __ ] sick don't get me wrong but i
can tell by the way people speak about
that i haven't got the love for it that
other people have do you know what's
crazy about that sorry to cut you off
the only reason why i continued to work
because i remember starting formidable
alchemist
and then stop in and then watch in
brotherhood and then stopping not like
not finishing
i think it was you and rem that
persuaded me
yeah you've just said now it's people
that persuaded you to watch it
so it's weird but yeah it was just like
it got so much love and i was gonna have
to watch it
and i did enjoy it yeah yeah bit of a
slow burner yeah
but it took like
for example you know the episode where
the the the the scientists dad
transmutes his daughter into and the dog
to the chimera
the chimera dog in the in the yard i
remember that was one of the heaviest
scenes of anything i've ever seen
i remember that but if that episode had
come
five episodes later i never would have
made it that far because i was just like
it was just
it's just another anime yeah it's just
it's just it took a while
it took a while to get slow burner yeah
real slow burn i think it's probably my
fault for watching it at the time i did
i watched it way later than everyone
else and when the time it came out
i probably would have loved it because i
haven't seen
that much it's like it's like watching
[ __ ] any classic movie now
it's like you're never going to love it
the way you should have loved it
watching how the time
literally like uh like it's the same
with one piece it's why i can't get
through one piece oh
i'm never watching that because it's
just too late now mm-hmm
this is what we've seen so much other
[ __ ] that got their inspiration from one
piece yeah that
nothing i watch in one piece is going to
hit me now yeah it's been done
it makes sense um which is not one
piece's fault but yeah so i'm going to
say
so what was it fullmetal narrative
naruto bleach
hunter full metal is going to go
okay and this is the last one
in the group and then we're going to
circle back cool cool
so you got new girl yeah how i met your
mother
yeah the office yeah big bang theory
oh i think
i know which one you're going to choose
and i think it's going to be that one
okay i don't know if you guys can see it
i'm going to choose that one
the one i'm going to choose to go
is big bang i know the boy big bang is
the best friend quiz um they should have
been the best friend yeah
big bang is one of the one is the only
one
on there yeah that's never succeeded in
making me
actually tummy laugh okay it's always
been like
huh like it gives me those loss it's an
enjoyable watch
but it's always a there's
that makes sense but there's only i
think there's only one time of actually
tommy laughed in big bang theory that
comes to mind because i
laughed in these other ones the office
made me laugh
you girl made me laugh how many of me
laugh but there was a time where
howard wanted to bang his wife what's
his wife's name again
howard um i can see you i can't remember
yeah i could see her facebook yeah high
pitch yeah yeah
um he i think he was wearing a costume
like this i think when he was talking
about space a lot and his wife was
getting vexed or science yeah yeah
and i think there was a time where he
was coming out the bathroom or saying
and he was wearing like some shorts and
he was like
shimmy you know if i was slightly like
that i can't remember the exact scene
but when i saw it and you know how
howard is he's stupid
i was the only one that actually makes
me laugh because howard is uh he's
character
his character is a such an idiot but
he's such genius yeah he's such tedious
but yeah so he's the only one that's
actually made me like laugh
yeah yeah yeah yeah but yeah okay so
we're gonna circle back now yeah so we
have to go through again
oh my god so
one's got to go breaking bad
game of thrones vikings
and i think you are you will probably
pick
oh that's a tough one because i'm
thinking what i would pick
and i think you will go
for [ __ ] have you finished vikings by
the way
no i haven't either i'm gonna choose
vikings to go yeah
and you're going to pick that great show
yeah
um but f really falls off
towards this season there's a reason i
haven't finished it
falls off towards the end okay
um but [ __ ] solid show but breaking
bad
and game of thrones come on man
those shows are next level all right my
hero
yeah jiu-jitsu kaizen yeah kimizunoyeba
my hero i love my hero as well
wow but justin and demon are just
they're doing something different it's
tough it's tough bro
ah i feel like a backstabber rick and
morty
south park simpson simpsons simpson's
gotta go all right say no more
[ __ ] the legacy now naruto yeah
bleach yeah hunter rex hunter bleach
i knew you'd pick that um
new girl how i met your mother the
office
how many times you can pick that
cool cool let's go let's go
this is stressful
boom one's got to go yep breaking bad
yeah game of thrones
oh wow oh man
guys make sure you're playing at home as
well
whatever you're breaking back game of
thrones breaking bad game of thrones
breaking bad game i know
i think i know who you're gonna choose
i'm gonna
say
breaking bad really i picked game of
thrones for you
i would love to say game of thrones
but game of thrones represents a time in
my life
which was like like a like a renaissance
of tv for me
okay where breaking bad was just like
binge binge binge game of thrones
like brought me back to the the kid in
me that was like
i need to get home for seven or eight
whenever it was on
and there were times when i was speeding
home fam i remember times
running home from the gym not to miss an
episode bro
not to miss the intro the whole country
the whole world
in fact stood for watching bang on it
every single week
i've never known a show to do that in my
lifetime that is very true
that is very [ __ ] true but as soon as
you said run at him i literally remember
running home from the gym yeah i
remember i'd finished work when i was pt
and i would finish work at
yeah at eight and i need to get home in
time for nine
and i think that's because i was
watching on plus one at nine i think it
came on at eight
normal maybe i'm wrong i can't remember
it's either came on at eight normal or
came on a nine on when i watched their
ten either way
i'd watch it on plus one and i'd just
not i literally wouldn't look on
instagram
okay not look at [ __ ] instagram i
can't until i get home and watched it
yeah
it every single week bro every monday
nah no show has ever done that in my
life so
james rose has to stay that's such a
good point
this is tough now g yeah jiu-jitsu
kaizen are commencing oyeba
that's an impossible choice well it's it
has to be i'm gonna say
i think you're gonna go for
i think he's gonna go for this one i'm
gonna say the one to go
is jiu jitsu you
love kibatsu i think it's wow i put
kimetsu
the reason i say jiu-jitsu is probably
just because it's less episodes
by what two uh yeah well actually no you
it's not even two of the episodes
it's to do with the character
development
okay there's more swing in um
jiu jitsu there's more arms in there
yeah yeah
and just the battles are insane yeah but
the actual
character development yeah like power
power development yeah is is consistent
but the character development like you
fall in love with the characters in
um demonstrations you [ __ ] do yeah
and
um you fall in love with um i can't
remember maine on his name now
in in demon slayer uh it's uh i can see
him
i'm so terrible with names i can see him
he's [ __ ] like cheer doing that
screaming at screen right now they know
he's an anime geek um i can't remember
his name i'm so bad with names
what is the main guy's name in flipping
demon slayer uh
demon slayer characters
is tangible tangiero
you fall in love with my man from the
jump yeah where he's like looking after
his family he's trying to sell all the
coal
so he can get home and stuff like that
and just like you fall in love with
like his relationship with his sister
and you really like um
you when he goes through his training
and he has to cut the rock
and he's going through all of this
hardship to get it and just like bro
like
i forgot about the rock cutting thing
yeah and he's he's getting trained by
these kids that are actually dead
and like brought the whole thing and the
scene where he meet
actually meets the main demon yeah
in the [ __ ] street and he's with his
family pretending to be human
and he's screaming through had he's
screaming that he's gonna kill him
he's screaming to the top of his lungs i
will kill you bruh for what you did
they only showed that once and they've
not looked back i [ __ ] that was that
was probably around episode 10
11 maybe i forgot about that bumps into
my man grabs his top
man turns around he's got you he's got a
wife they're saying who is this guy
a man says i'm gonna kill you bruv he's
screaming at him as he walks away
because he quickly turned the next man
into a demon in it so tandra had to hop
on my man to deal with this
and he's screaming at him you can feel
it jiu-jitsu doesn't have that
it doesn't have that like emotional
rollercoaster it does in elements
where like yuji dies for a bit and
whatever and stuff that has that in like
bite-sized bits but no massive build up
to an emotional release they don't have
that
yeah but don't you think obviously this
is going on attention up i don't care
don't you think that because of the fact
that it was only
him that went to his grandad's um not
necessarily if you know but only visited
his granddad in hospital yeah and his
granddad said um
make sure there are people around where
you die or something like that some
stuff along those lines obviously
and we don't even know um i've
said like make sure loads of people come
to your funeral yeah um i forgot his
name now
um it's not gojo it's um
well the main guy yeah the teacher no no
the main guy in um jujutsu usually yuji
sorry
um um he we don't even know anything
about his parents
nothing so we've got no real backstory
about him
and i think i think in terms of
manga maybe jiu jitsu is longer than
commencing that's probably why
it's taken a bit longer for character
development as a poster
oh yeah yeah i'm not blaming jiu-jitsu i
have no issue with the development that
they've done
i'm just saying from what because i i
can't do the choice based on what i
might see yeah i can only go on what i
have seen yeah
very true very very very true yeah based
on that judiciary has to go
but ask me again in next year or
whatever after season two it might be
completely different yeah yeah but
right now just gotta go unfortunately
because i love it okay so don't worry
cool gang gang
gang yeah you've got rick and morty and
you've got south park
i think you will probably what this is
obviously one to go want to go
i think you're gonna pick this purely
for one reason i think you're gonna pick
this for one reason to go would be rick
and morty i knew you'd pick that
i just wiped circled as well why south
park
is actually for me like a life-changing
show
in terms of it is a show that
it's like the first show i've for
starters i've been watching south by
since i was too young to watch south
park yeah i've been watching
since i was a kid and it's
the one of the only shows that's kept
the integrity
kind of like you know when i was going
these long rants about like [ __ ] like
i hate council culture
and people should be able to say what
they want to say and it's all the intent
and stuff like that
like south park literally rips everyone
to shreds
like they rip everyone to shreds and
they do not care everyone can get it
just as bad yeah but no one has an issue
with it
because they literally divvy out the
clout to everyone
they clap everyone bro and no there's no
one survives it
and no one cares because they understand
the intent behind south park is just to
rip everything to shreds
and no it's never been cancelled it's
the most cancelable show
on planet earth it's never come close to
being cancelled yeah yeah yeah
there's basically like the
i'm pretty sure what uh was it family
got them who had an episode taken down
because they drew a picture of muhammad
i don't think it was family guys so it
might i think it was south park
they might have had one episode got
cancelled where they actually had
they had mohammed there
these men don't care they don't care
don't care i think it's the only episode
they got taken down
maybe but yeah they don't care oh wow
and i just love that
i love that it's just like you can't
cancel south park
because they are so
racist sexist everything to everyone
that there's not one thing you can
counsel them for true you'd have to
everything they've said about black
people they said about whites for
everything they said about asians
they've said about black people for
every thing they said about trans people
they said about gay people straight
people like
everyone gets it and it's just like
there's nothing you can say is that are
they transphobic but they're also
heterophobic like
they're also like racist they're also
like sexist like they're
they're everything which means they're
nothing they're nothing yeah yeah they
have no biases
which means they're they're a council
free show they're council free show
they've never been cancelled
they're like ep season 20 something
well so that's why south park will never
get off south park anyway
okay on to the next yeah yeah naruto and
hunter rex santa and i think this for me
is a hard one
to know which one you're going to choose
but i think
you're going to choose this one to go
even though i'm
i wouldn't choose that yeah i think the
one to go
is unfortunately
hunter and you'd like that that's why i
circled yeah and i think i know why
because of naruto like the legacy you
grew up on it that kind of stuff and
obviously they had the
first one and ship it in yeah it's more
about the yeah it's definitely about the
legacy for naruto
naruto was my gateway anime it's like
the first
apart from like dragon ball z when i was
a kid and i didn't really know what was
what
now it is the first anime that i really
just watched
all of it hundreds of seven hundred
episodes
about that all of it since i was 15 16
um
15 i was when i watched the first
episode um
and it's like i've made friendships up
based on naruto alone
and um hunter as much as i love it
doesn't deserve the love it gets from me
considering that they haven't made an
episode since 2011 and that actually
it's not finished it's not
finished like you you don't get to be
the best of all time
yeah makes sense it's not fair it's not
yeah but i love
i love hunts i've seen it two times
maybe three
love it i've not seen naruto more than
once i'm never watching that again
let me say let me know let me not say
never because i've seen it all and it's
[ __ ] fantastic i will never forget
the first time i saw him fight zabaza
and i was like oh my and this was this
is
naruto young young young narrative yeah
oh my god i watch things
as well i've watched i started to watch
it again
and i've watched up to zabuza
but it's like i think if i'm going to
watch it again i should start from ship
it in
okay i think i'm okay to talk shipping
again but all the way from the start
it's like
just the the the animation alone is just
so
garbage yeah and it's like man you know
the backstory i know yeah yeah you've
seen it all and it's just like cool
but anyway yeah naruto's days cool gang
last but not least one's got to go i
think it's going to pick this one
so you've got the office and you've got
new girl oh office stays
i knew it office days 100 but i actually
haven't watched all the episodes of new
girl
have you not no okay i've watched a fair
amount but i've not watched all the
episodes
i've watched i haven't finished office
yet but i'm close
it's great office is
one of the funniest most genius things
i've ever seen
and i messaged you the other day saying
when i finished this i don't know what
to do with myself
the last episode is it's like [ __ ]
it's like what now man yeah because you
get so invested in
every single character bro and every
single character they all start to
sprout at different times
bro creed comes out in like season eight
he's hilarious hilarious creed is
hilarious
kevin comes out in like season seven
eight angela comes out a lot later on as
well oh
angela that's a great show man oscar has
like
peaks and troughs throughout yes yes
because he dips and comes back yeah
andy is just like yeah man all of them
they have there just moments
and you're like bro i wasn't even
expecting that it's a great show yeah
yeah
it's good man but yeah that was fun good
i'm glad you liked
it fun i'm glad you liked it because
you've got a lot more of this to come
gang that was fun uh so just to let you
know so your last um so your winners are
game of thrones kemetzunoyeba south park
naruto and the office cool let me know
what you guys got at home
or put in the comments below yeah let us
know what um which ones had to go and
which one stayed
that was fun alright guys thank you so
much see you soon
[Music]
catch